for years i have been working on a
simple idea
for humanity to take its next sleep
ahead
we need to work together across borders
to solve global issues
in the modern world no word or border
can protect us from crisis
we have no other choice but to unite
and we need to do it fast in 2016 i was
devastated by the uk's decision to leave
the european union
i'm french and for me the eu is a symbol
of a more open and global society
but suddenly my beliefs were shattered
and i wasn't allowed in feeling this way
my partner andrea who is italian and
darmian a german friend
also felt the shock of seeing the world
turning inward
we realized that despite being from
three different countries we witnessed
the same challenges
migration flows being dealt with in an
inhuman manner
climate change or high youth
unemployment and we also had the same
hopes and dreams in our everyday lives
we also realized that to solve european
issues the outdated model
of always putting national interests
first had to go
so we decided to act for a few months we
worked on the idea of launching vault
the first pan-european political
movement
and then naturally we told our facebook
friends and a lot of them
responded saying they were up for the
challenge and wanted to help
people started holding small community
meetings
in parks universities and pubs to
discuss their common future
and share their solutions to the
continent's biggest problems
we mobilized tens of thousands of people
across 28 european countries
two years in damian was elected to the
european parliament
on a campaign run by volunteers across
borders
on the idea that we're stronger together
we showed that by collaborating across
borders
by uniting and acting as one we could
start changing how people think
we were the first ones to attempt
something of this scale and to succeed
despite this after the european
elections in may 2019
andrea and i looked into each other's
eyes and asked that frank question that
you never want to ask
once you have worked for two years
towards something that actually worked
out
is this enough no it wasn't
we knew that today's urgent challenges
are not just european but global
we also knew that we couldn't even
attempt to solve them by only focusing
on europe
a continent that represents less than 10
percent of the world population
the underlying issue is that the way we
see the world and the way the world
works are fundamentally wrong
in the span of two generations the world
has changed more than in the previous
20 000 years we can land on the moon
we can wake up in shanghai and go to bed
in new york
we have access to a huge amount of
information all the time
everywhere but we still see the world as
our immediate vicinity
but issues like covet 19 climate change
migration
fiscal justice or human rights mean that
we need to
think and unite beyond national borders
a global approach is needed to solve
them
countries need to collaborate share
resources information and solutions
it's not just the right thing to do but
it's also the smart one
so in the weeks following damian's
election andrea and i
decided that we would create a global
movement to unite people beyond voters
and solve those issues that concern us
all we call that now
because we're not very creative and
because it needs to happen now
so i know that going beyond national
borders is not the easiest thing to do
so here's the framework that has been
guiding our work i call it think
unite and leap forward first we need to
change the way we think about the world
whether we like it or not we already
live in a globalized world
we need to stop thinking within national
frameworks and start thinking globally
take for example how we think about
taxation
multinational companies like facebook or
amazon
already operate across borders but they
pay
very little taxes in very few countries
because we think of them within national
frameworks
and as a result we lack a global tax
system
due to this countries are deprived of at
least
500 billion dollars annually 500 billion
dollars to put it in perspective with
half of that amount of money
we could put an end to global hunger for
one year
but we don't because of the way we think
about the world
at now we want to change this we connect
people from all across the world
who discuss work together and understand
that global is the new normal and that
they have more in common than what
separates them
we host weekly events in which we
discuss topics such as
lgbt rights pandemics fiscal justice
or mental health we break down those
global challenges to see how they impact
people in various parts of the world
and our members have already shown their
global thinking actively rallying their
governments
to solve those issues like ensuring a
fair distribution of vaccines across the
world
second after changing the way we think
we need to unite beyond borders
this way we can make governments act on
global issues take the example of the
erosion of democracy in hong kong
china has systematically cracked down on
rights democracy and freedoms
but countries have barely responded to
protect hong kongers
and i don't mean weak statements of
condemnation that won't lead to any
actual change but proper responses such
as sanctions
that's why now a couple of weeks back we
launched a campaign
to demand that democracy is ready to be
able to stand up meaningfully to china
and to get the attention we started
hosting weekly
protests in front of chinese embassies
within a couple of weeks
we engaged more than a million people
online
our hope is that by uniting and
mobilizing people across borders we will
be able to successfully lobby nations
into imposing coordinated sanctions
on china finally we must have the
courage to leap forward to create the
world of tomorrow
we need a system of governance that
works for us all across the world
and while some supranational
institutions like the united nations
exist
the enforcement mechanisms are extremely
limited
citizens cannot participate and national
interests often prevail
and on the national level political
parties are bound by electoral
timetables and borders
which means that they cannot operate in
a coordinated global manner
policy making governance and politics
need to stretch further take the example
of the response to the coveted 19
pandemic
countries have shown an incredibly
short-sighted approach
to the pandemic they haven't
collaborated when it comes to protective
equipment
vaccines or medicines at now we launched
a campaign
demanding that the world health
organization ensures that health workers
across the world regardless of their
nationalities
get priority access to future carbon-19
vaccines
we leverage a network of doctors on
social media to raise awareness
and started a petition targeted at the
whole
for two weeks our members spread the
words digitally
and on the streets and then we got a
response from the director general
of the who welcoming a campaign
re-emphasizing that the power to do so
lies within member states
but committing to working with them in
that direction and look this was a very
nice letter
but it was completely pointless the who
cannot
act meaningfully on this issue but the
point is a united nation
agency should be able to act
meaningfully should be able to create
binding policies and implement them
when faced with a global threat right
now
the most we can hope for is for some
world leaders to hear a scream
and decide to do the right thing this
cannot continue
in a globalized world we need
a true democratic and accountable global
system of governance
and that's also what we're working
towards but i know that global
governance will not happen overnight
for this we need people to push their
governments to act in a global manner
to show that collaboration leads to
better results
we need to prove the case before we can
change the way the world works
so this is my framework think beyond
national borders
unite across the world and leap forward
to make sure that the world
actually works as one and i know it is
easier said than done but it is doable
take our case as an example now was only
launched on the 1st of january 2020
but to already count thousands of
members in more than 100 countries
we are beginning to see that it is
possible to unite beyond borders that it
is within our reach
and we're not special nor am i in any
way
i don't have any cool skills and the
photo giving this talk terrified me
but i am testing different ways to
affect change on a global scale
because i know that national mindsets
and national frameworks have to leave
room for something bigger
for something better my hope is that
within my lifetime
i will see what living as one world
actually means
that by uniting we will be able to
safeguard democracy
to protect the environment to save lives
by sharing vaccines
to create safer routes for migration
among many other achievements
i don't know whether i have the one
solution no one does
i don't know whether now will be
successful in achieving these goals
but this is not the point the point is
that you should take action to affect
change on the global scale
my hope is that many of you will start
to work together across borders
that you will create and innovate new
ways for the world to be truly one
because yes we are stronger together so
what are we waiting for
thank you